[APPLAUSE]
MARY ROACH: Hello-- hello.
I like the oriental carpet.
Last time I went around
doing a round of talks,
someone had cut and paste into
my speaking contract something
from one of the
Food Network chefs
that required an oriental
carpet of certain dimensions
and flowers.
And they had to be all of one
particular blue, not another.
I didn't know this
and I kept showing up
and people would be like hi, our
oriental carpet is a little too
small.
And I was like, what
is wrong with people?
And then I found out that my
[INAUDIBLE], this had happened.
It was horrifying.
So I would show up and
go like, it wasn't me.
It's not me.
Anyway.
Hello.
Hi.
It's lovely to be here.
I've been at the Google,
the mothership down
in Silicon Valley, but
I've never been here.
And it's very nice.
So the book that I'm running
around town promoting
these days is called
"Grunt-- The Curious Science
of Humans at War," which
has kind of thrown people
a little bit because
it seems like sort
of a dark and somber
and serious topic.
And it can be.
But the angle that
I cover is-- I'm not
writing about weapons
and bombs and strategy.
I kind of leave that to the
Discovery Channel and Wired.com
and lots of other places that
do quite well covering that,
because the human body,
that's kind of my bag.
It is a bag, of sorts.
So I am covering sort
of the human experience
of being in combat.
So we're talking about lethal
heat and extreme noise and fear
and panic and maggots
and flies and diarrhea
and all these things you
don't necessarily associate
with military deployment.
Obviously the combat is what
comes to most people's minds.
And I got interested in
this book, I was it India.
And I was reporting a
story for Smithsonian
on the hottest chili--
arguably the hottest
chili pepper in the world.
There are people who disagree.
But it's called
the Bhut jolokia.
And I was up in Nagaland, the
extreme northeast of India,
reporting this story.
And while I was
reporting on the pepper,
someone said, you know,
the Indian Defense Ministry
weaponized this pepper.
And I'm like, I need
to know about this.
And the science arm, one of the
science branches of the Indian
Defense Ministry is in the
neighboring state of Assam.
So I went over there and talked
to folks about the pepper.
As it turns out, they never
deployed the pepper powder
because it was prone to mildew.
And so that sort of set
aside, while I was there,
I was saying well what
else do you guys do.
And they were testing a
leech repellent that day,
or had been testing.
And I said, what's
that entailed.
And he described going
down to the river
during monsoon season,
going down to the river,
rolling up their trousers,
trying on these leech
repellents.
And I thought, god,
military science
it's kind of Mary Roachable.
It's kind of not
what you would think.
And I had expected to spend more
time with the Indian Defense
Ministry, but they
had finished up
with the leech repellent
project and they were not
particular interested in
my poking around there.
So I came back to the
US and pursued it there,
and assumed that it
would be very, very
difficult to get access.
But in fact the Office
of the Secretary
of Defense of the United States
has a public affairs office
that deals with books.
And you can send them
a very brief, kind
of larval in my case
proposal saying this is
what I'm interested in doing.
And they will sort of give
you kind of a generalized nod
of support.
Now initially I
had thought that it
would be a very formal support
with embossed letters and gold
trim and something
that I could present.
But in fact it's just an email.
They could very easily have
taken out the not when they
said yes, we're fine with this.
Because as one of the
people there put it,
Mary Roach writing
about this science
is really not-- this is
not a big concern for us.
We're concerned about
"Zero Dark Thirty."
And we have other-- I'm just
sort of this trifling piffle.
Go and do your little science,
diarrhea whatever thing you're
going to do.
So people were fairly helpful.
It's also a side of
the military's work
that doesn't get
a lot of coverage.
And some of the work that
goes on is pretty cool.
And it's nice for
those people to get
a little bit of the spotlight.
So that's what
the book is about.
And I started out
the end of the book.
So it was kind of
strange process.
The first place I went was the
Armed Forces Medical Examiner
System in Dover.
And that's where the military's
main mortuary and morgue are.
And when I went
there, I kind of knew
that this would probably
be the end of the book,
because it's a little dark.
It's a way to kind
of wrap up, in a way,
the various wanderings
of the book.
The science that I was reporting
on there was pretty amazing.
It's called feedback
from the field.
And any time a body comes
in to the morgue in Dover,
it's given an autopsy.
All bodies are autopsied.
And what's different
about these bodies
is that all of the
lifesaving equipment
is left in place,
whether it was a needle
decompression for a collapsed
lung or a tourniquet.
And there's some new
technology in tourniquets,
or an airway device to
create a second airway.
All of that's left in place.
And it's part of the autopsy.
And then every month
there's something
called a combat
mortality teleconference
in which all the people at
the morgue and also some
of the research facilities, and
then the actual folks overseas
who had provided the
medical care, the emergency
medical care, all
of those people
are in this teleconference.
And they go case by case.
They take seven or eight
cases and they have slides.
And they discuss it with
the aim of identifying
things that have been
possibly going wrong,
equipment that isn't working
the way the manufacturer thought
or it wasn't placed properly,
just getting at the question,
is there anything that could
have been done differently,
any way we might have
saved this person's life.
So that was a really
interesting and of course very
sobering afternoon.
And one of the things they'd
recently figured out-- this
was just kind of
an amazing thing
you don't really think about.
The number one pastime on
these big bases in Afghanistan
is body building.
And some of the
soldiers, their pectorals
are so buff that the needles
they were using for a needle
decompression, which
is if you've been shot
and the air that you're inhaling
is ending up outside the lung,
it can become difficult
to inhale and you can die.
It's, I think, the
second most common cause
of fatality in combat.
Anyway, so they
realized the needles
weren't making their way
through the muscle to the space
that they needed to
decompress that pressure.
They were not sure why
this was-- what's going on?
Why were these people dying?
And so it was kind
of great that they
were able to figure this
out, get the information out
there quickly through
a teleconference
rather than waiting
for somebody to publish
a paper, which is usually the
traditional route to making
that information available.
And because it's
a Mary Roach book,
people are like whoa, how's
she going to make that funny?
How's this book going to work?
So I ended up-- there's a
couple of historical chapters
that dealt with the-- they
both had to do the OSS, which
was the precursor to the CIA.
And the OSS had some interesting
projects in World War II,
including something
called Who Me?,
which was a foul
smell in a tube.
The idea would be
to distribute it
to resistance groups
in occupied countries.
And so motivated citizens could
go up behind a German officer
and discreetly squeeze, fire
this tube and spray this.
And it was interesting
because the language was all
describing it as a weapon.
They had specs, like it has
to be lastingly penetrative.
It has to withstand rain,
dry cleaning solvents.
There was a range
that it had to cover.
And it had to do
this at-- it had
to stink for at least
two hours at 70 degrees
Fahrenheit at a certain level.
And the whole thing
was sort of documented.
And they'd hired out
this chemistry company
to figure it out.
And there were all these
memos that went back and forth
about what is a stink.
It's all in the
context actually,
because something like
butyric acid could smell.
If you're in a deli it would
smell like Parmesan cheese.
But if you're not in a deli,
it smells like dirty feet
I think it is, unless it's
vomit-- anyway, vomit.
So they were looking
for something that
would be universally repellent.
So there was all these
conversations back and forth.
Oh yeah, the other example in
this memo about what is a stink
was trimethylamine, which
is a fishy smell which
could be pleasant or unpleasant
according to circumstances.
And trimethylamine is,
in the tampon world,
used for testing the powers
of deodorant of the product
that you have.
Anyway, enough said.
[LAUGHTER]
Anyway, the tubes,
there were all manner
of problems with backfire.
The weapon was backfiring.
The tubes, the little lead tube,
the crimping wouldn't hold.
There was one guy
who, at the OSS,
actually set up a
mannequin with a uniform.
And he took a box of the tubes
and he tried to spray them.
There's this very testy memo
saying that most of them
had sprayed back at him.
And anyway, it was just
sort of a delightful chapter
in military espionage
and goings on.
So the Who Me?
Was-- the tradition of bad
smells as nonlethal weapons
has carried on at the Monell
Chemical Senses Center
where I spent some time
there in the late '90s.
The Joint Non-Lethal
Weapons Directorate
commissioned sensory chemists,
as in smell and taste,
at Monell to come up with a
universally horrible smell.
And this woman Pam Dalton
went around gathering data,
all over the world.
She had, in her suitcase,
she had little bottles
labeled burnt hair, sewage, US
government standard bathroom
malodor, garbage, sewage.
She was doing a
project in South Africa
and she thought, well I can get
some more cross-cultural data
here.
And she had this 15 hour flight.
And in her carry on she
had all of her smells.
And she describes getting up
from her seat after three hours
to go to the
bathroom, standing up
so her nose is about the
height of the overhead luggage
and going oh my god,
those are my smells.
She forgot about the change in
pressure and they were leaking.
And so she said to her seatmate,
you cannot open this overhead
bin for the entire 15 hours.
Everything you have at your
feet, that's all we can have.
And then she did this.
When we land, I don't
know what I'm going to do.
So they land.
She waits for the doors
to be open on the plane
before she opens the overhead
so that people will go huh,
I guess that's just how it
smells here or something.
And in the end, the
winner among burnt hair,
which was kind of a stand
in for burning body, which
was thought that would
be universally abhorred.
But in fact when you
interviewed some-- there
were all these different
cultural groups that
had to say, is this pleasant,
unpleasant, wearable.
Is it a wearable
scent, an edible scent?
And for every one of
these horrible scents,
there would be some group that
was like yeah, I'd wear that.
I'd wear that as perfume.
I'd eat that, because
it's all out of context.
The one that just upset
and horrified everyone
was US government
standard bathroom malodor,
which you can still get.
And that is something
that was devised to-- they
were trying to come up with
a deodorizer for latrines
in World War II.
Some of the open pit latrines,
really nasty smell, intense.
So they tried to mimic
that smell so they could
test deodorizing compounds.
So this is a really vile smell.
I have smelled US government
standard bathroom malodor,
and it is pretty bad.
So that was where they started.
And then they're very clever.
At Monell they really
know their smells.
What they did for this
nonlethal weapon is they
added a kind of floral,
fruity, sweet top note to it.
Because when you're presented
with an unknown smell,
you take a tentative
little whiff.
And if that top node
is nice, then you
do what's called
the keeper inhale.
So people go oh, this is nice.
And then they'd get this,
this like wall of smell.
And it tends to stay.
Something about it-- Pam
Dalton is the chemist.
She was like, it keeps
rebinding to the receptors
and you get it
stuck in your nose.
And I have, in my closet,
a sample of stench soup
that is in a bottle,
sealed, with paraffin,
double bagged in a box.
And I haven't had the
courage to open it.
It's kind of like
this mystery box
that's just sat there
for over a year.
And I don't really
know-- I thought maybe
I would bring it to the
Republican National Convention.
I don't know What I'm
going to do with it.
But I will open it somewhere.
I thought maybe, oh
I'll bring it along.
I could bring it to Google.
And then I thought, it could
get into the ventilation
and you guys could be
on the street for days.
So I have to be a little bit
careful with my stench soup.
So anyway, that's stench soup.
But for the most part,
some of the humor
is kind of the
historical elements.
And the other thing is
just I'm such an outsider
to the military
culture, and it really
is a culture, a foreign culture.
And I've not spent
any time in it.
My family is not military.
My dad was 65 when I was
born, so he enlisted.
He came over on the "Lusitania."
In World War I he
enlisted in the military.
Born in England, he
was-- I found his papers
at Fort Moultrie.
But my dad got a hernia
in basic training.
That's the illustrious
Roach military saga.
So it's not a personal
history by any means.
And I don't know a lot of
people in the military,
so it's fascinating to me
to be kind of in this world,
sort of thrashing around.
And I would find
myself-- I mean,
sometimes the humor came just
from that, that kind of I'm
really out of my element here.
I was in Djibouti, which
is a North African nation
above Somalia,
across from Yemen,
which obviously gives you a
sense of what goes on there.
A lot of counterinsurgency,
special operations stuff
goes on there.
And I was on the base.
The special operations, those
folks are in a restricted zone
that you need
clearance to go into.
So I went over there
with Captain Mark Riddle,
who is a diarrhea researcher.
He's an MD and he was testing
a much faster, one dose
regimen for diarrhea,
traveler's diarrhea,
a particular kind of E.
coli that's fairly common
and is pretty nasty.
He was over there testing that.
And the rates of diarrhea just
among the average deployed
soldier in 2003 to '04, 77% of
soldiers and personnel had come
down with diarrhea, 40% bad
enough that they sought medical
care, and 32% had it bad enough
that there was a time when they
didn't make it to
a bathroom in time.
And if you can imagine a
special operations mission,
these are fairly
critical, high risk,
kind of take out Osama
bin Laden style things.
And if you are hit with
this sudden extreme urgency,
you can't just go, could
someone else cover me,
because I've got [MOANS],
not feeling well.
So it's kind of a matter
of national security.
And that was my take on it.
So I thought OK, I need
to just talk to some
of the special operations guys.
They're easy to pick
out because they
have beards and no one
else there-- everyone
else is clean shaven.
They need to fit in with
the local population
in these villages.
And they the public
affairs guy is like Mary,
I sent out an email for you, and
I've already humiliated myself.
So it became known as
the diarrhea email.
Will somebody please share
their stories of diarrhea
with our visiting writer.
And nobody-- well, some
people did, but no one
from special operations.
Oh, I will.
So he said, you
know, Captain Riddle
said, "You're going to have
to talk to them over dinner.
They only come out to eat."
And Seamus, the
public affairs guys
goes, "And to steal our women."
Anyway, so my only
opportunity to talk
to these individuals, who are a
little intimidating to someone
like me, was in the
dining facility.
So it created this kind of
wonderfully awkward scenario
of crossing the room to
approach this very sort
of stony and omnipotent
seeming person eating
by himself, who just kind
of looked up at us and said,
I'm done.
And Seamus said oh, could I
ask just what line of work
are you in.
And he said I'm leaving.
And he got up to go.
And I had to jump
in and sort of just
say, "My name is Mary Roach.
I'm working on a book.
And I wanted to talk
to you about diarrhea.
I know that it sounds
like a silly topic."
And he looked up
and said, "It's not.
You're welcome to sit down."
So it was a very interesting
conversation and a very unusual
reporting challenge.
Anyway, the thing
about the book is
one of the reasons I went
ahead with this book is
because the topics are
things that anybody
in the military deals with
a really extreme version of,
whether it's overheating or
back pain from heavy loads
or sleep deprivation or
hearing loss from loud noise.
The science of
these topics would
be applicable to anybody who
has a body and ears and a back.
The culture of the
military is interesting,
but also just the
science of-- you know,
the science of sweat
and heat stroke--
I mean, it's a big problem
because the situation that
creates heat stroke is this
competition for bodily fluid,
specifically blood.
Because your sweat is plasma.
It's the clear
portion of your blood.
And when you start to
overheat-- your body
is a machine that wants to be
in a set temperature range.
And if you stray
from that, it does
what it can to bring it back.
And the first thing it
does is generate sweat.
So all the blood is
shunted to your skin,
and the plasma comes out
through the sweat glands,
and then kind of
vaporizes and takes away
the heat from your body.
And that's great.
And it's very, very efficient.
However if you are
exerting yourself,
if you're carrying a heavy
pack and you're running,
especially if you haven't
hydrated yourself well,
you have this competition for
a limited amount of resources.
And at a certain point, somes
got to go to the muscles,
and it's got to go to
the blood to cool you.
And your body will start
to shut down other things.
You might not get enough
blood to your head.
That's why people pass out
when they're very, very hot.
Or your gut can
start to shut down.
And that leads to a sort
of a chain of events
that can result in delirium,
coma, and then you're dead.
The military was trying
the-- medical school,
USU, Uniformed Services
University of Health Sciences
was working on trying
to figure out--
because there's a lot of
individual difference in how
well you acclimate to heat and
how badly you suffer from it.
So the idea was, well,
could we find a blood marker
or is there some sort of genetic
difference between people?
Can we identify who
is really at risk
and keep them out
of this scenario?
Which is a great plan,
and it was interesting
because they have
the cook box there,
which is a box that they can
adjust the heat and humidity
and sort of create a really
god awful hot day in the Middle
East with a treadmill
and a backpack.
I lasted seven minutes out
of the hour and a half.
It's pretty brutal.
And my pack only
had 30 pounds, which
is about what the body
armor itself would weigh.
So it's unbelievable how
fit, how these people are,
and what they endure.
Something that seems like
would be a good answer,
it's a little tough
because what happens,
you take people out of--
it's like OK, this guy,
obviously, we've
been able to identify
these people are not going
to fare well in extreme heat.
So let's hold them back.
And then so the people who
are fit end up doing more
than their fair share.
They're the only
ones you can call in
to do a really hard job.
And so they push themselves
and then collapse.
So it's just really hard.
There's an environmental
medicine unit at Natick labs
that has a mannequin
that sweats,
that they figure out
these sweat prediction
equations where give me how
many miles, how hot is it,
how much are they carrying,
what's the body armor.
And then you plug it
all into a formula
and it tells you this is how
much water per person to carry.
So they're trying to get it
dialed down to a science.
But ultimately, when you
get into the real world
of a mission, there's
always five or six things
nobody counted on.
It's just really
hard to hand someone
a formula that's going to
solve all their problems.
And the soldiers are
like, these scientists,
these rules that
these guys in air
conditioned offices
come up with.
So there's kind of a
tension between the soldiers
and the scientists.
But they're all trying
to do their job.
And the one thing I
wanted to do for the book,
I initially had
planned to embed.
This was when there was still
stuff going on in Afghanistan.
And I was going to embed.
I initially had an idea I wanted
to embedded with the 4th Marine
Corps Dental Battalion, just
because that whole concept
of a Marine Corps
Dental Battalion
just really appealed to me.
As I said, I had a notion
of these guys parachuting
in with little picks, smocks.
Of course that's not the case.
And they're like yeah, well
we're not going anywhere.
Thanks for your interest.
So the Marine Corps Dental
Battalion was off the list,
sadly.
But I still like to talk about
the 4th Marine Corps Dental
Battalion just because there's
a dental battalion, a Marine
Corps Dental Battalion.
Similarly at one
point I thought it
would be-- because
my editor of course
was like, special
operations, can you
go out with a special
operations team?
I'm like, I kind of think that's
classified stuff, but I'll try.
So I called the Special
Operations Command Public
Affairs Office.
And I thought OK,
I'll cover-- what
about, because they have
their own weather command,
their own weather people.
Because if you're
flying in somewhere,
weather is important.
And it's a critical element.
But I could just imagine, it's
a just a very elite group.
And if you made it into
special operations,
and then you got
to brag about that.
I got into special
operations-- special operations
weather command.
So I thought that
would be interesting,
that these folks would
have an interesting take
on the whole thing.
And I explained that to
the public affairs guy.
And he said yeah, that's
just not going to happen.
It's classified.
And I actually said to
him, "But I'm only going
to ask questions about weather.
So I won't pay any
attention to anybody else,
what they're doing."
No-- no.
So there were some walls that
were thrown up, understandably,
in my efforts to
report this book.
But I made my way onto a
ballistic missile submarine,
the "USS Tennessee," which
was a fascinating place to be.
They had been a serious
issue with sleep deprivation.
Most of the guys at that
time had been averaging
around four hours sleep.
It's kind of not what
you want on a vessel that
is powered by a nuclear reactor
and carries 20 some Trident
missiles.
So they were trying
out a different watch,
because a submarine is isolated
from the normal queues of day
and night.
The thought was, well maybe we
can muck with circadian rhythm
and create a different
length of day,
thereby making things
more productive.
But in fact you had
a situation where
they might have been a
little less sleep deprived,
but it was like flying
to Paris every day
is how someone put it.
That circadian
rhythm was just off.
Their body rhythm was
off with the clock.
So they were trying
something, moving it back
onto a circadian
friendly time schedule.
So that's what was going
on the "USS Tennessee."
It took me a year and
a half to get on there.
Not because anybody
was saying no, just
because its very
hard to find somebody
who had the
authority to say yes.
So you get a lot of,
well it seems OK to me,
but I'm not the one
who can say yes.
So you kind of get
bounced around.
The Djibouti trip, I think there
were probably 60 or so emails
flying around over the
span of three weeks
to just try to go with
the diarrhea research
to Camp Lemonnier.
And the Navy public
affairs person was like,
seems fine to me.
I don't even know,
is it CENTCOM?
Is it AFRICOM?
Is it Joint Horn of Africa?
Is it the Pentagon?
I have no idea who to ask.
I don't know who can
sign off on this.
And finally it came down to
that guy Seamus on the ground
in Camp Lemonnier who had
seen all these emails pinging
around, and finally said--
because I asked him,
"How did you make this happen?"
He said, "Well you
know, at a certain point
I thought, this is
not like diarrhea.
You can't just hydrate and
wait for it to go away.
Somebody has to do something.
So I went into the base
commander's office and I said,
'Do you care if this woman comes
here to talk about diarrhea
with people?' And he's like, 'I
don't care.'" So they said yes,
that's fine.
So weeks of formally petitioning
the wrong person over and over
and over.
And in the end it was just
the guy on the ground.
Sorry, I have a
little bit of a lost--
I've been talking a lot lately.
So I should probably sort of
wind it down and take questions
from anybody who has questions.
Or if you wanted me
to talk about any
of the other
subjects in the book,
I talked also about
genital injuries,
which is something we've been
seeing lately for two reasons.
There's been that the
bombs have gotten bigger,
and also the emergency medical
care and medical evacuations
have gotten better and
faster, so bigger injuries
and more people surviving them.
It used to be if there
was a bomb big enough
to damage the pelvic region
rather than just blow off
your foot, you didn't survive.
And now these guys
are surviving.
So there's interesting
reconstructive work,
some of it coming
out of cooperation
with the transgendered
community, which build penises
all the time.
What do you need to know?
Anyway, so there's that and
lots of other fun topics.
But I'd be happy to talk about
any questions people have
or about any of my other books.
AUDIENCE: So you do
a lot of research.
How much actually
makes it into the book
and how many of these gems
are just left on the floor?
MARY ROACH: Oh well, I
write everything down.
Because when I go
somewhere, I don't really
know what the chapter is
about quite, because I
haven't met these people.
I don't really know
what's going to happen.
So I'm just writing
everything down.
I would say 0.01% of what I
write down I actually use.
It's insane.
It's so much just
stuff that-- And I'll
go back and look at a notebook,
I have no idea what I was even
writing down.
So no gems.
The gems, no.
The gems go in the book.
In fact when I go on a reporting
trip, I go back to my room
and I go through my notebook.
And I have a system
where if it looks
like a promising something
somebody said or something
that was interesting,
I'll circle it.
And if it's really good, I'll
circle it and put three stars.
And I go one, two,
or three stars.
So I have this rating system.
And I pull that stuff
out into a transcript.
And then I print that out.
And then I go through and
circle stuff in there.
And I move the really good
stuff to the top, kind of just
like this is the good shit.
This is going to go in somehow.
And that actually influences
how I shape the chapter.
Like if there's a scene
that is really great,
that seems like it would
be really fun to read,
I'll figure out, now what's
the order of these two or three
scenes.
So I identify the
scenes and quotes.
But most of it, yeah.
Most of it just--
And when I was on the
submarine at one point,
I was interviewing
someone and something
was said over the intercom
that was classified.
And the ship's
commanding officer
said, "I'm really sorry, you'd
going to have to delete that."
And I said, "It's an MP3 file.
I can't go in.
I mean, you guys probably could.
You can't go in and
just delete a word."
And he said, "Well,
you're either
going to have to
delete the whole file,
or I guess I could
transcribe it."
I'm like, yeah.
So this guy is so busy.
He's got so much on his plate.
And this annoying journalist
who's there for four days,
out at sea, I kept going
by his little state room.
He's hunched over his computer.
And it was the most beautifully
transcribed, every word
written out, spelled perfectly.
You know, Mary Roach, colon.
It was like a screenplay.
Whereas when I type it, you
could barely figure it out.
I abbreviate every word.
Anyway, so that's kind of
my haphazard procedure.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was very interested to hear--
you talk about the autopsies
at the beginning
of your remarks,
particularly in the nonmilitary
world, a lot of doctors
are concerned that they're
not doing enough autopsies.
They're not learning
enough from their mistakes
or their problems.
Do you know anything about how
the information might flow?
Do the military doctors write
papers or data summaries
from what they learn
in their autopsy work?
MARY ROACH: I think
they do write papers.
They do that conference just
to get the information back
to the medics and the
emergency room people.
But I think they do go on and
write papers based on what
they're learning from autopsy.
Autopsies, like
hospital autopsies,
that's an interesting realm.
I know the medical examiner in
the Bay Area-- of course I do.
We go have lunch.
She's like "Oh,
I've a decomp today.
You want to come over?"
I'm like "Hey, not so
much before lunch, no."
She said that there
is sometimes--
she didn't give
me any specifics,
but there might be pressure
on the medical examiner
not to find negligence.
That was upsetting to me,
like that the whole idea
with an autopsy is to get at
the truth of what happened.
Probably that's not
a regular occurrence,
but that was sort
of disconcerting.
So I think there's some politics
behind prevalence of autopsy.
It tends to be done when
the cause isn't obvious,
when it seems suicide or
homicide is suspected.
But people die in hospitals
and the family wants to know.
You can get a private--
you can call 1-800-AUTOPSY
and they drive up in a van.
You can contract someone
to do an autopsy.
So that would be an
interesting realm to explore.
I don't know that much about
it or whether I have even
answered your question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MARY ROACH: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I am a huge
fan of your books there--
MARY ROACH: Oh thanks.
AUDIENCE: --highly entertaining
and very educational.
And I have not read
"Grunt" yet, though I'm
very excited to do so.
And a lot of the things
you've spoken about
are the physical--
the smell, the bodies.
Do you touch or have you touched
on the mental side of things
and technology and
innovation in that space?
MARY ROACH: I was going to after
the 4th Marine Corps Dental
Battalion turned me down.
I had planned and got permission
to embed with the Chaplain
Corps, because I wanted
to cover PTSD-- or not
PTSD, but just specifically
emotional issues
and how a variety of them, like
dealing with a death in a unit
or whatever comes up.
And the chaplain, the chaplain's
assistant who has a weapon
and covers for
the chaplain, they
go out on missions with a unit.
Which I hadn't
realized, I thought
they stayed back on base and
had an office that people
would come too.
But they'll actually go
out on a route clearance
mission or whatever it is so
they can offer this empathy.
I wasn't interested in
the religious element
so much as their
ability to empathize
because they've kind of been
through similar hardships.
And that fascinated me.
And I was really disappointed.
I was approved by
the US, but then
ISAF, which is the coalition
umbrella organization,
said no because
it's the drawdown
and we have hardly
any journalists.
And I think it was more
like hey, you didn't ask us.
Who says you could go?
Somehow he saw an
email and was like hey,
you didn't talk to me.
I don't know.
Do you know what
they say ISAF stands
for-- I suck at fighting.
That's my little dig at
ISAF for turning me down.
No, I don't even know
ISAF, international-- I
don't even know-- what
does ISAF even stand for?
International-- it's
those guys, the overseers.
It's the coalition.
But anyway, because I didn't
really have a narrative--
I didn't find another way in
that would afford kind of-- I
like to have sort of a
scene and a setting thing.
I think I had a chapter
in "Packing for Mars"
that had to do with sort of
unique psychological components
of being in space.
And I had planned to do
that but didn't end up.
And there's a lot
of coverage of that
as well that other
people I think
have done a nice job with.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Looking forward to reading it.
MARY ROACH: Thank you.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: After spending so
much time in your research,
did you find your
opinions related
to the military, its command
structure, its politics,
the soldiers, their
lifestyle or their worldview,
did you find your opinions
changing on that at all?
What was kind of the
before and after of that?
MARY ROACH: Well the
before was that I
had this view of the military
as a sort of monolithic entity.
Which the more time you
spend in that realm,
the more you see
how fractured it is.
There's not just the different
branches of the military,
but there's the policy
people in the Pentagon
and then there's the scientists
and the medical people
and the civilians who work.
And so it became really hard
to have any single opinion.
I ended up having a
tremendous amount of respect
for the researchers
who do this work, which
is going toward trying to
make this god awful experience
somewhat more tolerable
and survivable.
Those guys, those
people-- a lot of them
were women actually in
the book-- were great.
And so that's the main
world I inhabited.
So I don't really have-- I
mean, my views on the larger
entity of war and military
policy, et cetera,
have not changed.
But that did change.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I was
interested to hear
you talking about the circadian
rhythm stuff on the submarines,
especially because
since I read--
I think "Bonk" and "Stiff" were
the first two books I read.
I've been wondering
if you were ever
going to do a book
specifically about sleep.
MARY ROACH: Yeah, people have
suggested-- did I cut you off,
or was that your--
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
what do you think?
MARY ROACH: Well, two
things are going on.
My editor at WW
Norton just edited
a book called
"Dreamland," I think,
on sleep, the science of sleep.
But more than that, because
it's dreaming and sleep,
it's an internal state,
trying to imagine
what would be the scene
and the setting-- it would
be like chapter after chapter of
a guy on a bed with electrodes
asleep.
So it's kind of hard to--
And you know how when you
tell your spouse or partner
your dream, and they're like
instantly like, shut up,
it's so boring.
Please don't tell me your dream.
So trying to describe--
I mean, not that it would
be entirely about dreaming.
But it felt a little
confining in terms
of the color and the scenes
and kind of the narratives
that would bring the research
to life, for that reason.
But it is-- and I have
given it thought, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Cool, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank
you for coming.
My wife is very jealous that
she wasn't able to come.
You're one of her
favorite authors.
Have there been any
themes for books
that you've started
pursuing and then abandoned
because they didn't
actually bear enough fruit?
And if so, what were they?
MARY ROACH: Yeah, there was
one idea I had for a book
that morphed into
"Packing for Mars."
But originally this guy
I knew from way back
when had gotten a
job in Galveston
at the bed rest facility
connected to NASA where they're
studying muscle wasting
and bone loss from being
in weightlessness because
your body kind of just
takes apart your muscles.
We don't need these, we're
going to take them apart.
So there's lot of bone
loss and muscle wasting.
The analog for
that, the simulation
is to have people lie in
bed slightly head down
and not get up for three months.
They're paid $17,000
or something.
And I thought wow, the
whole human Guinea pig world
seemed kind of
interesting and bizarre.
But I talked to my agent.
He's like, "It seems like it
would be a little repetitive.
Is there enough variety?"
I mean, a lot of people are
testing drugs, pharmaceuticals.
That is an interesting
world, but that
has been covered a fair amount.
So again, it was
a situation where
I didn't know that there was
enough variety or my agent
didn't think that there
would be quite enough
variety to the landscape
to make it a go.
So I folded that into
"Packing for Mars."
AUDIENCE: You do a lot of
traveling for your research.
And it seems some places kind
of recur from book to book.
And I was wondering,
on any given trip,
how many different projects
are you working on at a time?
MARY ROACH: On any given
trip, often just one chapter.
AUDIENCE: Wow.
MARY ROACH: Yeah.
Well the India trip,
I was traveling
with a friend who was
doing some charitable work
for an organization called
Books and Water that
tries to put in
wells in villages
and portable libraries.
So I was traveling with her.
And then I she was
going to be in Nagaland.
And I was Nagaland,
I've never heard of it.
So I looked it up, heard about
the chili pepper contest,
and pitched that.
So I was doing two things there.
But usually when I
travel somewhere,
I'm only doing one
chunk of research.
AUDIENCE: And here I was
envisioning some huge master
plan.
MARY ROACH: Yeah, you
know what, I'd love that.
It never works out that way.
And sometimes it
will be like, I've
got to go to London for this.
And then six weeks later
there's another thing.
And I can't combine them because
it's all their schedule, not
mine.
So I'm constantly sort of
being buffeted here and there
by researcher's schedules.
Things get pushed
back and delayed.
So I never go on a vacation
myself because I'm like,
my cadaver project might
come through next month.
Oh, it's been delayed.
So I am constantly-- And I
don't do a lot of talks outside
of book tour for that reason as
well, because I may need to up
and go quickly.
I wish.
Anyone else?
All right then.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks a lot.